after last week's brutal brexit bashing
in Salzburg it was just another normal
cabinet meeting say number 10 have you
checked out objective the first chance
for those ministers with doubts about
the PM's brexit deal to have their say
are you checking out checkers with a new
threats from the opposition inside a
discussion on whether EU citizens should
be offered preferential access to the UK
and if not whether free access could
last another three years but post
Saltzburg
checkers Wars discussed as the brexit
Department released more No Deal
preparation notices we had a good
healthy discussion the Prime Minister
made clear we're going to keep our calm
hold our nerve and press the EU on some
of the criticisms that they've made but
also to be clear that there are no
credible alternatives that the EU has
come up with so we're going to hold our
nerve but continue to negotiate in good
faith this is the most severe sets of No
Deal notices we've seen from the
government covering these threats of
aviation services road haulage licenses
a requirement to have a green card for
motor vehicles going through Europe and
even restrictions on the transfer of
your pet cat and dog the farmers union
called it catastrophic the food and
drink Federation said it would be a
grisly outcome but right now
No Deal increasingly plausible such
stark consequences being planned for is
part of the reason the opposition has
once again inched its brexit policy in
the direction of its remain backing
membership our so-called people's votes
on the deal on the table
if the PM's deal is voted down in
Parliament and the government refuses to
have an election I think it'll be on the
deal itself with we're saying we respect
the referendum it will be about the
nature of the deal what that the Prime
Minister brings back or the one that we
can negotiate and the shadow brexit
secretary going much further asserting
that's remaining in the EU could be an
option meanwhile back in Westminster the
Tory Rebel Alliance gathered to support
a free-market think tanks alternative
brexit plan no two checkers yes to a
more simple free trade deal approach
were currently bluntly
in a cul-de-sac I'm afraid I cited this
Vizsla I think Salzburg was
unfortunately all too predictable and it
gained the endorsements of a big beast
biding his time
it's the alternative that the Prime
Minister originally wanted to do at a
Lancaster House because it enables us to
do a big free trader with great free
trader with European Union but also to
do free trade deals around the world a
PM with much to think about ahead of her
conference speech as she prepares for a
trip to the United Nations telling a US
network of her frustration with EU
negotiators there's a plan on the table
from us if they have they have issues
with it let's hear what those issues are
the immediate challenge to get her new
plans for the Irish border completed and
signed off domestically and by the
European Union
all those No Deal notices risk becoming
reality Faisal Islam Sky News